Could you, could sketch
what's wrong
from your perspective
with subjective rights,
right, you're one of the sharpest critics
from theological circles in, in, in the kind of
Christian theological circles of subjective rights that are kind of
underpin
the whole liberal democracy. That's a,
that's a huge challenge, right.
And so it may be helpful if you would, if you would sketch in a few points
what is, what you see as a problem with that. Maybe that's going to generate our discussion.
I know that we read some of that, but, but if you could maybe
remind us of it that would be helpful.
Well I think
they most generally speaking, they,
they, they, they place the focus wrongly in trying to understand
human community,
what
theologically speaking I would refer to as moral community,
that is to say, the whole community of human goods and rights, not using the term "moral" in any narrow sense.
I think they misplace the focus.
It ought to be on
human relationships with God
and with one another
and not on individuals.
That is the first point.
The, the, the,
stemming from that
is the question, "Well, why
this focus on the individual?"
And as I make, I've made this point, of course, in my, in my
interpretation of the history of Western rights
and again today that I think that focus has had from the beginning
had
an interest in seeing human
freedom, that is to
say, the, the capacity of human beings to choose
to do one thing rather than another,
to make one moral judgment rather than another, one judgment rather than
another, that very capacity
has been seen as the, an originating right
on which all other
human rights
are based,
erected, the foundation of the building of human rights.
And that is the case I think from the canonists onward,
that is not simply part of, one might sa,y
the Lockean-Hobesian project, the, the later project.
And the
understanding of the individual
as a proprietor,
someone who
both,
who,
who governs him or herself
precisely because they own
their
capacities and spiritual resources and they own their
acts. In a sense they make their
acts and they have a proprietary
control to dispose of
the, a proprietary right to dispose of themselves and their acts as they,
they wish to.
This, this is a,
a conception which implicit
and, and
drawn-out has accompanied the path of Western human rights
more or less from the beginning
in, in, in various stages of sort of explicit-ness and
elaboration. And that it seems to me
runs clean contrary to an understanding of human beings as essentially
oriented in
their,
their communal and individual lives
to their relationship to God,
and, to, to
their neighbors.
Their relationship to God
being one,
as I indicated
a few moments ago,
being one
primarily
of, of adoration,
love, gratitude,
reverence, and
openness and obedience
in the sense of openness
to
divine,
the divine will as it reveals itself both in
our natural perceptions of right and also as revealed to Christians in Scripture.
So,
the main point really is
about the misplaced focus
and from there one can go on to, to
a,
a spectrum
of theological
and philosophical criticisms.